now I can help you kids hope you gain
now miss lay the wheel jabber walk walk
with me Marcos
watchdogs too is here and putting you in
the driver's seat in a world where
almost anything you can imagine can be
hacked to your heart's desire there are
a lot of ways to spend your research
points to improve your hacking skills
but to know which ones to get right off
the bat can be tricky but controlling
robots hacking security sensors and
calling in angry reinforcements will
cover it all in our best starting out
hacking skills unlocks guide and
watchdogs too you've got a weird
relationship with technology you know
that right
I got something being outgunned is no
fun so how about calling in some
much-needed help in the social
engineering tree after you've unlocked
create distraction go ahead and grab
gang attack next this ability allows you
to tag any security guard or cop with a
gang bounty on their head once the word
is out a crew of gangsters will show up
and either join you in the gun battle or
play great distraction as you go around
the shootout either way this is a great
ability when needed during some of the
close shootout moments in the game
robots have the next wave of the future
so why not put them to good use working
and dying for you
in civvy disruption tree after Auto
takedown grab the robot exploits now
there are two ways to use this ability
and/or combo them the first is if you're
surrounded by foes and you need to enter
a secured room hack the robot and select
the music icon this will throw the robot
into dance mode grabbing everyone's
attention next say if someone sees you
breaking into a device hack the bot
again and click the heart icon this will
turn the bots in to a Love Machine
charging headfirst into anyone harassing
you if guards are nearby they will open
fire on the bot destroying it but giving
you the time you need to move forward
speaking of moving forward and
undetected the next ability under city
disruption is called security system
shutdown this ability allows you to
shutdown scanners for a brief time
saving you the trouble finding alternate
routes and lock down situations
combine this with your robot exploits or
gang attack abilities and you'll become
through those security checkpoints in no
time have you ever dreamed of driving a
scissor lift or a forklift me neither
but now you can you're going to want to
when you unlock it in the remote control
tree under environmental RC with this
ability you can now gain access to areas
unavailable before stealth missions can
now be accomplished with ease since you
can enter through high windows and
rooftops plus you can gain the ability
to reach research for suitcases that
allow you to gain abilities faster if I
had to choose one tech tree not needed
to upgrade unless you have the extra
points lying around is the marksmanship
tree if you're well versed in
third-person shooters you won't have a
hard time getting headshots also fairly
early in the game you'll unlock the
silenced pistol from your monstrous 3d
printer once you have this gun there
won't really be a need to use the stun
gun anymore and a few abilities in this
tech tree go towards that weapon it's
your call hackers but one thing for sure
send a few points to your botnets tree
to give more battery power so you can
use your hacking abilities more often
unlocking the first three apps in this
tree will do just fine starting out last
but not least once you get the
quadcopter this is an excellent hacking
- in PvP moments because of its size and
speed you can locate your target when
being hacked very quickly when hacking
someone else you can remain at a safe
distance while your drone does all the
work however if it's spotted it will
point to your location so use it wisely
save your money to hackers you're going
to need it to buy this thing and there
you have it fellow hackers a quick look
at what abilities best suit you the
moment you step into the big city what
abilities are you looking forward to
using and watchdogs to share your
thoughts in the comments below and I'll
see you guys next time for all things
video games keep it here on gamespot
signing off
searches cure you